hey guys I have a problem where I have
become like the master again in the
friend zone
so I have some questions for Sally as I
figure what better way than to ask a hot
girl for advice on how to get out of the
friendzone okay what do you think are
some of the first steps that first get
you into the friend zone most guys that
I don't even look at them as romantic
and they come out to me like really
quickly okay I like you it's kind of I
to do right now so you're just gonna be
my friend
you know well let me tell you a basic
version of what I think even if a girl
finds me attractive at first then I'll
be so funny whatever what tends to
happen with me is I'll meet a girl Thank
You laughs a little bit but then I get
personal with them they start to open up
to me about stuff that they never talked
about with anyone they feel like you
know what you're like a best friend cuz
I could tell you anything we just have
so much fun together which sounds like
what a relationship should be but they
tend to friendzone me when I get to this
point where they feel comfortable with
me and everything yeah see I think the
main reason why guys get friendzone is
because if you really like someone
something that gets me is mystery okay
or just don't treat me like all the
other girls that you're flirting with
because that's just immediately already
I'm like you do that with every girl I
don't think you're safe that is a big
problem just don't open your self as
much the girl needs to be guessing if
you get the girl guessing about you that
is a very good sign because that will
trigger her to want to be interested in
you to want to find out more about you
I've heard the advice of it just asks a
girl a lot of questions does that work
otherwise what the hell do you talk
about
I don't wanna grow with that you don't
yes
get to know her but don't be so much
trait you're only just asking her
questions because then she'll get the
assumption that is guy really walks
through a lot about me clearly
interested and now I'm the one being
wanted so they kind of have the upper
hand huh
so I have to show that they are
different but show I'm not that
interested no guys - on that persona all
the time up there they like me or
anything very pretty and so they
immediately did the same for good things
and you know what to try and feel like I
like what really gets my attention is
when the guy shows like no interest in
me even if I only look at them as a
friend sometimes I'm just like why have
they shown no interest in me whatsoever
see I've heard this before I want to
treat a girl like a lady though I mean
very gentlemanlike but also be quiet and
just act like that's just how you are
you're just the gentleman all the time
not with just her how do I be just me at
the same time be a little bit more
conservative when you're just but then
when you're in a group saying they'll
see that other side of you that's one
tiny and then they'll want to get that
out of you interested don't show
interest but somehow make this rule on
us no talk to me this is this is very
different what if you're already in the
friend zone how would you get out of it
just like you got out of the friend zone
and then all the guys show interest in
someone else work on your human smart
and I don't mean you're the person you
you look down on my belly no how would a
guy get out of the friend zone with you
you think I'm really gonna pay attention
to this one what I found out is when I
friend zoned a guy and they just take it
as cool completely move on go on to the
next and kind of like about it because
they got cool look for them it's kind of
like make it look like you're
someone else and the girl kind of be
like why do I need to ever me ah I like
this plan okay
isn't it a little offensive to the girl
though that I'm not showing interest in
because what if you actually expresses
interest in me you know the girl I'm
using that's a way to use the girl it
could be a happy accident and the girl
use great circle of life
okay so express an interest in someone
else let that be known so still be
friends with the girl walk to the grow
back I'd be like okay look I know we're
just friends I need advice on this other
girl Oh what happened to me I've been
friend-zoned before believe it or not
you've been friends of friends owns a
girl and then later on I showed interest
in other guys this guy was like is she
hot and then I just picked myself up a
bit started becoming more girl and he
was just like why can't my girlfriend be
more like Oh or girlfriend
what's up see with my experience what
tends to happen with that is the girl
will tell me oh I was an interesting as
I thought you were interested in this
other person usually lie so they lie
remember that guys
most the time when girls friends those
guys they come up with a really stupid
excuse to friends on them because
they're just not attractive I know
they're not attracted to them or the guy
reminds them of like a family members if
they don't like you know something
personal but then they make it seem like
it's not something personal I'm gonna
take your advice and put it into action
everything yeah you did but I'm sure
there's a bunch of people out there have
their own questions so why don't you
guys put in the comic box of Sally hot
girl who knows the keys into getting
into the girl's pants life nerds oh yeah
subscribe to Sally's Channel oh yeah
no seriously subscriber channel she's
got a bunch of really cool [ __ ] and she
has a lot of other stuff in the pipeline
that just sounds awesome yeah when he
said pipeline is pictured you see me
haunted by that image I just want God I
don't want to know that it goes either
way look it just goes somewhere don't
even know where to go ever gonna visit
the Senate now ain't no way guys never
there
thank you well end it on it really
crappy no no no